la comisión europea ha presentado su
esperada ley de chips el objetivo es que
europa aumente la producción mundial de
estos semiconductores tan importantes
para sectores como el del automóvil y
también el de los ordenadores así se
espera que de aquí a 2030 el 20 por
ciento de la producción mundial de chips
se haga en europa además europa sobre
todo lo que quieres también en reducir
la dependencia que tiene respecto a
china y taiwán que crean gran parte de
estos chips más aún cuando en los
últimos meses ha habido graves problemas
de escasez y entonces esto también ha
provocado que muchas empresas europeas
hayan tenido que paralizar su producción
debido a su incapacidad de poder tener
estos semiconductores a tiempo la idea
es que hay una inversión pública inicial
de aproximadamente 30 mil millones de
euros para la creación de fábricas de
chips también para atraer inversión
privada y para la investigación en total
se espera movilizar aproximadamente
45.000 millones de euros bruselas
también facilitará las ayudas y los
subsidios para crear
a orillas de chips que son de por sí ya
muy caras bruselas asegura que su plan
es muy parecido al que ya presentó eeuu
recientemente con una inversión de 50
mil millones de dólares